what was this misleading information
what exactly is the EU saying Facebook
did well when Facebook bought what's up
and went to the European Commission to
ask for permission they said to the EU
that they couldn't link that they
technically couldn't link the Facebook
user information with the Watts up
information now two years on as we saw
over the summer they announced that they
were doing just that that they would be
able to show [ __ ] Facebook what's up
advert to advertisers and film there
what's up information so by linking
those that information the Commission
says well this is not what you told us
before and can you please be a bit more
precise about what precisely happened
now the regulators are being have an
open mind let's say so far about whether
that was deliberate or not but they say
it doesn't really matter the fact that
you didn't give us the full facts at the
time that apparently this was
technically possible is a problem and
that's something while it won't overturn
the merger it could lead to a fine for
Facebook and and what's the size of this
fine and what are the implications here
I mean is this being viewed as a slap on
the wrist or is it something more
serious well it's not great if you're
going to do future deal-making
which presumably Facebook might do it
sometime in the future that they're
already in trouble for possibly lying or
misleading regulators on what the facts
of the case are the fine is 1% of a
yearly revenue which for Facebook is a
pretty big number and they have about 17
billion in euralia revenue but the
previous fine we saw in this was 12
years ago and was only ninety thousand
euros so while financially it might not
have consequences reputationally it does
and not just maybe for facebook doing
deals in Europe but maybe elsewhere as
well yeah it's been a it's been a bit of
a an issue this year hasn't it the the
issues that various tech giant's have
faced in front of the EU Apple of course
and Google today but to just remind us
of the travail they're going through
ether it's it's been a pretty horrible
year for technology companies in
Brussels we've seen three cases open
against Google one of the most important
being answer Android operating system we
had a huge order to Apple to repay 13
billion euros and tax back to the Irish
government which they said yesterday
they'll fight we also see Amazon has a
couple of issues to deal with on tax and
with an ebooks case
I mean it's it's it's definitely a
jurisdiction where you need to tread
very carefully these are very powerful
regulators on a normal antitrust case
they can charge you up to 10% of revenue
but more importantly they can force you
to change what you do as we saw with
Microsoft to change the way you do your
conduct your business in Europe and
perhaps also globally and Facebook's had
other issues in you in Europe this year
hazard 8 I mean it's had its own pretty
terrible year in Europe in 2016 yeah it
seems pretty endless I mean we started
off with Germany having an antitrust
probe about privacy terms we've seen
another privacy a bunch of privacy
probes into the whatsapp merger issue
and also in hate speech and on fake news
we're seeing German officials be
concerned that Facebook might not be
doing enough to stem hate speech so it
seems fairly endless it's been quite a
tough year for them so if what about any
other sort of antitrust actions that
we're gonna see for the the tech
industry more broadly I mean it does
dewy regulators sort of is there special
scrutiny on that industry in particular
and there seems to be I mean new
industries bring up new problems we hear
regulators say that they do see
monopolies form very fast in these
industries the how the treatment of data
is something that regulators are
thinking about I certainly wider than
just antitrust but on privacy as well
which is a really a hot-button topic for
Europe and these are these are issues
which haven't always cropped up in the
US and that are becoming more and more
prominent in Europe and how people use
these services what we've seen now is
really the beginning of cases I mean
what we might see next year is some
conclusion seems moving forward on
against Google I get in this case
against Facebook and others so we might
see where these actually go to and the
companies right now have a chance to
defend themselves that's what Google is
doing so next year is when we see answer
is whether they managed to get to
convince regulators that they're right
or they find no that they're wrong there
was a bit of backlash politically and in
quarters to the to the Apple case you
know it needs to pay back whatever it is
13 billion euros in back taxes IVA under
the Trump administration do we have any
idea how the how President Trump and
he's when he when he finally is it all
grated will take to these sort of
measures against his sort of domestic
tech Titans who as we know didn't
exactly support him during his campaign
that's a very good question I mean
either the EU cases against Google are a
question that we've had whether the US
might look at Google again I'm some new
issues have cropped up since they
dropped their case but on yeah we are
seeing more friction between the EU in
the u.s. I mean the Apple case is a
special one because it's tax something
where the US Treasury has said very
clearly that it disagrees with what the
EU has done there were voices within
Europe that don't like what the EU has
done the Irish are not happy with that
their tax deals were ruled illegal
that's quite important to them that they
can attract big companies to them so we
are these are these are very
controversial issues it's it's Europe
does look like a tough jurisdiction to
do business for American companies for
big companies for companies that have
these kind of tax deals or these kind of
issues